le procès va se jouer en 48 heures pour
marie antoinette les chances de s'en
sortir sont infimes
quand on l'amène devant le tribunal on
l'a conduit au fauteuil qui lui est
réservé au milieu de la salle à ses
côtés l'un de ses défenseurs
chauveau lagarde en face le président
herman qui va diriger les débats
c'est lui qui prend la parole en premier
pour prier l'accusé de se présenter
nommé vous et impôts nets le règne des
rois de france
puis vient le tour de l'accusateur
public antoine fouquier tinville c'est
lui qui est chargé de couvrir
marie-antoinette de tous les maux
possibles et imaginables
il a rédigé l'acte d'accusation le
procès de marie antoinette semble être
jouée d'avancé les charges sont lourdes
l'épreuve difficile à réunir j'ai ici
devant moi le document qui va sceller le
destin de l'ancienne reine de france
il s'agit de l'acte d'accusation qui est
conservée ici même aux archives
nationales
on y accuse la veuve capes et le nom
qu'on lui donne pendant ce procès
d'avoir entretenu une intelligence et
des correspondances avec les ennemis de
la république et d'avoir tram et des
conspirations et des complot contre la
sûreté générale de la france en armant
les citoyens les uns contre les autres
et bien c'est sur la base de ce document
que marie-antoinette sera condamné à
mort
[Musique]
sitôt lu l'acte d'accusation
marie-antoinette voit les premiers
témoins défilé devant elle mais aucun ne
semble apporter la moindre preuve d'une
quelconque culpabilité
les débats sont désorganisés le défilé
des témoins et brouillon on va présenter
des témoins visuels qui vont évoquer
leurs souvenirs
autrement dit pour parler familièrement
c'est l'homme qui a vu l'homme qui a vu
l'ours donc d'y à gauche voilà parmi ces
témoignages inattendue il en est un qui
provoque un tollé
c'est celui du pamphlétaire jacques rené
hébert qui accuse l'ancienne reine
d'inceste sur son fils le futur enfant
du temps
marie-antoinette effondré semble ne pas
pouvoir trouver les mots pour se
défendre
pourtant la cour insiste pour qu'elle
s'explique
et à ce moment là mise au pied du mur
marie antoinette la quitte la réserve
habituelle qu'elle met dans tout ça 11
je n'aurais pas parce que la nature
elle-même rejettent une telle accusation
j'en appelle à toutes les mères du tout
pour les autres j'en appelle à vous
c'est le cri d'indignation trop c'est
trop
là elle peut plus elle peut plus aller à
les attaquer elle est attaquée au plus
profond d'elle-même
ça n'est pas la reine qui est attaqué
c'est la mer alors lui dit vous êtes une
mauvaise mère vous êtes pire mauvaise
mère vous êtes comment dire un monstre
et là trop c'est trop
en accusant marie-antoinette d'inceste
hébert a dépassé les limites
l'ancienne reine est atteinte dans ce
qu'elle a de plus intime la salle est au
bord du revirement
les femmes présentes se sentent soudain
concernés et l'estocade si
maladroitement porté par hébert se
retourne contre lui
l'accusation n'a pas porté l'accusation
a gêné le public l'a mis mal à l'aise
apparemment et donc on a oublié cette
accusation dans le verdict final second
peut savoir semble-t-il c'est que le
dauphin se livrer la masturbation
mais il est absolument impensable que
marie antoinette se son livre à la cesse
avec la avec ses enfants c'était absurde
ça n'a vraiment aucune sorte de
justification si l'on sait quoi penser
aujourd'hui d'un tel témoignage il
n'était pas à l'époque dépourvues de
crédibilité en salissant
marie-antoinette les accusateurs se
faisait le relais des innombrables
pamphlets orduriers qui depuis le début
du règne n'avait cessé d'entacher sa
réputation
ces pamphlets sont conservés dans une
section réservée de la bibliothèque
nationale de france surnommée l'enfer
guillaume mazeau nous les fait découvrir
pour la première fois le plus ancien
date de 1779 et s'intitule les amours de
charlot et toinette ce livre il est
vraiment passionnant parce qu'ils
montrent que contrairement à ce qu'on
s'imagine dès les années 1770 donc très
très tôt marie antoinette était vraiment
la cible privilégiée des pamphlets des
critiques des crises attiré
pornographiques même et ce pamphlet
invente une lubricité une perversion
morale et sexuelle de marie antoinette
en nous prêtant des amours avec le frère
du roi lui-même le comte d'artois les
yeux du fier d'ars ébloui enchantée
animée d'un beau feu par course et
beauté à qui n'en seraient pas en effet
idolâtre
avec la révolution ses pamphlets vont
atteindre des sommets de dérèglements
ils sont de surcroît illustré de la
façon la plus débridée la plus
outrageante comme ses fureurs utérine de
marie antoinette un livre publié en 1791
deux ans avant le procès
il est illustré avec des gravures
colorier donc c'est très moderne
les images nous permettent de d'appuyer
en quelque sorte le texte est de
désacraliser en encore de marie
antoinette et à côté du titre donc la
première image nous montre louis saez le
pantalon la culotte baissée le membre
impuissant devant marie antoinette qui
elle au contraire est complètement
offerte
[Musique]
ces pamphlets donne une idée de ce que
l'on pense à l'époque de marie
antoinette devant le tribunal c'est une
opinion largement répandue que ce qu'on
tente de refléter l'ignoble hébert
il n'invente rien et ben hebert c'est
finalement une soeur de capteurs de
l'opinion et c'est très très bien que
finalement utiliser les rumeurs les plus
infondée mais aussi les plus
scandaleuses soeur marie antoinette
c'est vraiment une façon de guerre et
peut-être de gagner le procès contre
marie antoinette qu'est un procès public
un procès médiatique par le passé la
reine n'a jamais voulu donner
d'importance à ces pamphlets source
pourtant de son impopularité
elle s'en est même amusé comme dans
cette lettre adressée à sa mère
l'impératrice
on m'a très libéralement supposer les
deux bouts celui des femmes et des
amendes relation lesbienne galanterie en
famille tout y passe
mais qu'en est il réellement
marie-antoinette at elle jamais prêter
le flanc à ce type d'accusation
marie antoinette a sûrement recherché ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des flirts il ya
quelques témoignages qui sont là mais
elle n'est certainement pas aller plus
loin du moins elle n'est certainement
pas aller plus loin
jusqu'à sa rencontre avec fersen
parce que là elle est réellement tombée
amoureuse de fersen lecomte axel de
fersen l'officier suédois que la reine a
rencontré par hasard au milieu des
années 1770
mais en vérité les rares indices laissés
dans leur correspondance sont codées ils
ne permettent en rien d'affirmer que
leur relation était est consommé
c'est une chose qui est très difficile à
prouver mais l'époque des faits à
l'étranger tout le monde était convaincu
que fersen était la mort de la reine
c'était un fait avéré pour deux pour
tout le monde sauf pour les français
un des épisodes marquants de leur
liaison et l'avenue secrète de fersen au
palais des tuileries un soir de 1791
il arrive à entrer aux tuileries alors
que la reine est la règle et sous
surveillance continuelle il arrive à la
voir et alors ils n'osent pas ce qu'il a
il a écrit un il a écrit un journal
pendant toute sa vie un total en
français et alors il écrit rester là je
suis resté là alors il ya eu des
discussions infinies sur ce thème rester
là parce que dans son journal il
employait toujours cette gamme reste
hélas pour lui reste hélas à vrai dire
j'ai couché avec avec telle femme
j'ai été voir telle femme restée là ça
veut dire je suis resté pour qu il
emploie ce terme pour la red alors est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il rêve qu'il a
couché avec la reine beaucoup de
l'historien le pense ou à qu'on en pense
cette amourette est resté très en deçà
des accusations salaces portées contre
marie antoinette
mais la rumeur n'en a pas moins scellé
le divorce entre une partie du peuple et
sa reine le 14 octobre 1793
lors du premier jour du procès ce
désamour est à son comble
[Musique]